Sau khi báo nhân dân có bài phản ngánh, dân nặc dụ vượn quốc gia bà vị, một năng công trình xây sự khẩu pèc.
Năng ngày 20 tháng sau, mới đây ngày 20 xa thằng sau, chú tịch bị bám nhân dân thành của hành lỗi, đã ra ui bám nhân dân vị bà vị, chú trì, khối hợp sử nông nghiệp và mù trường, các lần vị đến quan, khẩn trưng kìm chá làm gió thù tìm báo nhân dân phản ngánh.
Sử nhiên xa phạm được có, báo cáo ý bám nhân dân thành phố, chựa ngày 30 xa nè, báo người danh sau năm 2020.
Chức đó, cũng liên quan đến phản ngánh của mào nhân dân, bố trường nông nghiệp và mù trường đã yêu cầu cuộc lưng nghiệp và mù trường.
Cần trường thì gặp đoàn công tác, li cìm chá thực liệp, sắc mình làm gió các nội dung báo chi phản ngánh, có việc pháp sử li, lăn trạng kìm thời, các hạm đậm vi phản pháp lật thiệp thành, điều có.
Đông thời, ra xuất tàn bố các hạm đậm cho thuyền gì của mù trường dân, quản li và báo vị dân của vượn cút giả bà vị, báo cám bộ, mằng bản bản chức này, hai nơi làm tàn sau năm 2020.
Máo nhân dân sẽ thông tin tới quy khám dạ, kết quả của các đoàn kìm chá, cũng như những lỗi dung khác địa quản đến phủ việc.
Như báo nhân dân đã thông tin, tình trạng xây dự trên rất dừng đặc dục, tại hô dù li kênh sở xuống nhà thuộc vườn Quốc xà bà vị đã diễn ra trong thời gian dài khiến cạnh quan mù trường thiền nghiệp miếng nội, tình mạng dừng muốn xin nát, dường vông chá trở ra tỏng nất với đá, qua li gài của lãnh gạo vườn Quốc xà bà vị thì các hạm đậm trên nàng khác phục hộ quả,
nó pueden bảo số bao, khẩm chiến năm 2020. Tuy nhiên, quanh hiểu cửa phó viên mảo nhân dân. Đây không chỉ tớn thuần là khác khoảng lợc khắc phục hộ quả thì tại.
Mà còn có nhiều hặc muo công jình lực tến thành xéi mới. Trong hải vàc này mới đây, dừng đặc dục vườn Quốc xà bà vị đã bị thay đổi ra sau.
Phó viên có chỉ ra khủ thế nhiều vị chỉ, khu vực, nằm ngoài thương án đã được cấp phó thẩmb tiền phê dựng.
Bịt kến hạnh xây dự trất thử điểm cơm bạo số ba đủ bộ.
Từ đó, rất đến điều, diện tích các cơm chình trong cuộc du lịch thiệt sân xuống nha đã vượt quá tỷ lệ cho phép.